revenir sur la réaction d'Eric Zemour
qui a parlé également de Karim Benzema
tout le monde parle que de Karim Benzema
un truc de fou on dirait qu'il va
revenir en équipe de
francebat alors le président de
reconquête a dans un premier temps
déclaré que le foot français était de
plus en plus islamisé
regardez connait depuis longtemps on
sait que il a joué en équipe de France
par accident uniquement pour l'argent et
les résultats sportifs il l'a dit
d'ailleurs lui-même peut-être aussi
parce qu'il a un peu de talent ah il a
beaucoup de talent c'est c'est pas
incompatible mais je veux dire il n'est
pas français de cœur il n'aime pas la
France il ne l'a jamais aimé mais
au-delà du cas de Karim Benzema il y a
belle lurette que le football français
est complètement sous la coupe de
l'univers des banlieu et comme l'univers
des banlieu est de plus en plus islamisé
le football français est de plus en plus
islamisé et il a été très loin ERC zimon
puisquil a fait un lien il a fait un
lien direct entre Karim
Benzema la photo c'est pas la meilleure
il a fait un lien entre Karim Benzema et
l'assassin de domque Bernard regardez
pour moi Karim Benzema est un islamiste
je ne sais pas ce que c'est qu'un
islamiste moi ce que je sais c'est que
c'est un musulman qui veut appliquer la
charia et que la charia prévoit le
djihad et que le djihad ça veut dire
tuer Dominique Bernard ça veut dire tuer
ça vous faites un lien entre Karim
Benzema qui a ses opinions qui peuvent
être contesté contestaes on peut être
d'accord d'accord et l'assassin du
professeur de français vous faites un
lien entre les deux absolument je fais
un lien direct toutes ces personnesl
pensent que la ch est une loi divine et
que elle s'impose à eux et que dans la
charia il y a divers sourates et que
cette charia prévoit entre autres le
djihad qui est la guerre sainte contre
les infidèles les infidèles c'est vous
et moi alors sur Karim
Benzema non mais là que vous dites c'est
la surench de la récupération politique
alors on a mélchon d'un côté et zour de
l'autre crache sur le visage des 6
millions de musulmans de la de France en
gros c'est tu es musulmans tu es
extrémiste jihadistes ENF c'est tout ce
qu'on ne veut pas aujourd'hui en France
nous on veut qu'on on veut vivre en paix
on veut voilà on veut juste pas importer
ce conflit et eux ils font tout pour
attiser les haines et les rancœurs et
c'est je vous assure moi je suis super
désespéré quand je vois ça c'est un
énorme dérapage on peut pas faire des
raccourcis comme ça bientôt on va dire
que c'est Karim Benzema qui a commis des
attentats enfin voilà qui a des
suspicionss de de lien avec les Frères
musulmans c'est un fait puisque
gérardman l'as dit il faut qu'il y ait
une enquête et je ne comprends pas parce
que Eric Zemour lui-même est victime
pour d'autres raisons de ses raccourcis
c'est qu'on dit qu'il est raciste qu'
aime pas les Arabes et cetera et là il
impose ça aux autres on peut pas on peut
pas dire ça c'est grave de dire ça je
trouve il fait de Karim Benzema
quasiment un terroriste fa VO Kim Benza
j'aimais bien savoir comment il il le
prend tout ça il s'en fout total ou pas
tu penses ah mais non c'est pour ça
qu'il réagit via ses avocats non non ben
non les avocats Karim metzemel a des
avocats qui veillent sur tout hein tout
ce qui est dit sur lui n'oublions pas
qu'il y a vu l'affaire de la Sexte il a
été marqué par ça donc non non il
réfléchit eu d' il y a énormément de
gens qui ont réagi mais Karim Benzema ça
a été mais il a toujours ah ça dans sa
communication quand il est parti la
Coupe du Monde il est toujours
énigmatique il fait des post un peu
bizarres avec des légendes on comprend
pas les gens lisent entre les lignes on
imagine qu'il a une sorte de message
enfin un peu subliminal et tout ça donc
il est enfin il est connu pour ça
Benzema Jacques n'est-ce pas oui c'est
vrai qu'il a une communication qui est
un peu particulière on sent bien qu'il a
envie
de de défendre une cause et pas l'autre
et moi c'est un peu ça qui me choque le
concernant après
les pourquo Kim
Benzema
tout le monde parle que de ça ben
c'està-dire que il y a cette sortie de
geréral d'Anin donc évidemment à partir
du moment où puis ensuite la députée
qu'on a reçu hier et la sénatrice pardon
donc forcément il cristallise il
cristallise tout ça c'est cristallisé le
jour où il a décidé d'aller jouer en
Arabie Saoudite il a signé dans un club
et alors saoudien les déclarations qu'il
a fait où il disait qu'il était content
enfin de quitter la France parce que
voilà s'il avait joué en équipe de
France c'était pour le côté sportif
parce que son cœur ag il était en
Espagne il était au Real Madrid ou il
était content de jouer pour l'équipe de
France alors je vais te dire tu sais
qu'il y a plein de et qu'il a dit que c
en Arabie Saoudite qu'il avait enfin
trouvver la paix la réalité des choses
et que il se sentaiit en adéquation avec
l'Arabie Saoudite qui n'est pas la
démocratie la plus puissante du monde où
on on décapite les femmes quand quand
ell trompent leur mari et cetera donc le
fait qu'il ait dit ça bah ça engendrait
quand même un malaise pour tous les
Français qu' avait accueilli comme un
enfant mais je pense qu'près par exemple
le silence de Kyan Mbappé si Kyan Mbappé
avait fait le même message sur Twitter
par exemple que sur Gaza je pense que or
aussi un S de de vous croyez pas enfin
moi je pense je pense moins je pense
moins je vous dis la vérité je pense
moins on aurait trouvé malgré tout je
pense moin je pense que je pense pas que
le ministre de l'Intérieur a
réagit sur Kyan Mbappé je suis pas sûr g
tu es d'accord avec moi je suis d'accord
avec vous d'abord Ballon d'Or meilleur
footballeur du monde même s'il va perdre
ben non mais son impact
incroyable attention monsieur Dar dit ce
soir précisément que c'est la stratégie
il étaille son propos en disant que
c'est selon lui la stratégie des Frères
musulmans que de passer par des sportifs
euh des des des des stars du showbiz et
cetera pour essayer de faire passer des
idées c'est ça aussi ce qu'il ce qu'il
étaille ce soir dans son interview just
pour Karim Ben alors là là je vais
parler complètement d'autre chose vous
avez dit que Karim Benz était était
content quand il a quitté la France et
alors je vous dire il y a plein de
footballeurs avec qui je parle aussi qui
en France euh ils se font parfois voilà
bien sûr ils ont une vie exceptionnelle
mais parfois voilà c'est c'est ils ont
ils ont des moments compliqués réry avec
c'est surtout vis-à-vis des journalistes
c'est pas le public hein mais ils ont il
y en a il y a beaucoup de footballeurs
qui n'en veulent pas aux Français c'est
ça que les gens ne comprennent pas et je
vous le dis ça je voulais le dire parce
que ils en veulent au journaliste s'il
vous plaît Jacques je vous le dis Franck
ribéi quand il était ici c'est un joueur
exceptionnel les journalistes il lu tomb
dessus tout le temps il arrêtait pas de
le fracasser il est parti ailleurs c'est
c'était une star incroyable il était
respecté de tous et on je rappelle il a
toujours dit je ne parlerai plus jamais
au journaliste Franck Karim c'est un peu
pareil m rien c'est que c'est pas c'est
attention il y a beaucoup de
footballeurs qui n'en veulent pas aux
Français qui n'en veulent pas aux
supporters qui en veulent aux
journalistes je vous le dis donc il faut
pas tout mélanger non plus et qui disent
les journalistes français et ceux qui
nous tombent dessus toute la journée en
fait on préfère aller jouer ailleurs
parce qu'au moins on nous respecte et
que la presse nous respecte g est-ce que
tu es d'accord avec Mo vous avez raison
et sur riéi par exemple vous avez
toujours eu une vision de Franck ribéri
qui ce qui est vraiment la vraie vision
de l'homme et moi en tant que
journaliste j'ai une vision avec lui
conflictuelle j'ai écrit un livre ça mal
passé il y a eu des procès donc les ces
joueurs là estiment que les journalistes
effectivement déformment les faits pour
orienter l'opinion contre les suppors ou
contre les contre les médias de la
sphère médiatique les fait passer pour
ce qu' ne sont pas donc du coup eux ils
n'ont pas d'accès direct aux gens donc
qu'est-ce qu'ils font maintenant ils
communiquent via leur réseau c'est pour
ça qu'il communiquent directement fr
plus jamais parl à la presse plus jamais
parler à la presse française fait une
émission sur de médiia français parce
que il il a été dégoûté
il faut pas plus rentrer dans des trucs
là un moment un moment le problème c'est
qu' dans une psychose c'est que le gars
ça y est il aime pas les médias français
il aime pas la France il aime donc un
moment il faut arrêter un moment il faut
voilà Franck ribberry par il aime
beaucoup la France mais il déteste les
médias français et on peut le comprendre
je suis désolé on peut le comprendre s'
beaucoup à Boulogne de là où il est
originaire et cetera il fait beaucoup
d'action qui sont restés discrè parce
qu'il n'a pas voulu les exposer alors je
voudrais qu'on revienne sur une petite
infoz on est en direct donc on vous
donne toutes les infos qui tombent les
ché et il y a une info libération qui a
fait une énorme boulette le journal
Libération la Une du journal
Libération catastrophique
euh fait énormément parler d'elle parce
qu'en publiant une photo de
manifestation propalestinienne il publie
aussi une affiche brandie par un homme
et c'est en fait et auudessus surtout
cyil c'est la photo de ce bébé en
réalité une fausse image puisquelle a
été créé par l'intelligence artificielle
en février publ sur les réseaux il y a
des mois sans aucun rapport avec Gaza
exactement aucun rapport donc il se sont
fait totalement piéger on sent bien
qu'il y avait une volonté dans la Une de
Libération de d'éditorialiser la douleur
prétendu à travers cette ce qui s'est
passé dans cet hôpital mais utiliser
cette image qui est une fausse image
intelligence artificielle créée en
février 2003 est déjà utilisé sur les
réseaux sociaux donc c'est pas comme si
elle était apparue ces dernières ces
dernières minutes c'est c'est
franchement une grosse boulette et moi
je voudrais ajouter quelque chose dont
j'ai dont je voulais parler lundi mais
qui m'a profondément choqué c'est la Une
de Libération à la au lendemain de
l'assassinat du du du professeur
Dominique Bernard tué parce qu'il était
prof oui je suis resté scotché devant
cette une ça veut dire que Libération
décide à 22h au moment du bouclage 4h
après ce qui s'est passé qu'il est qu'il
est mort simplement parce qu'il était
prof il ferme le débat c'est
journalistiquement une honte absolue ça
veut dire que on prive tout le monde
Libération a décidé ouais qu'il était
mort simplement parce qu'il était prof
et qui avait aucun rapport avec un acte
terroriste avec l'islamisme avec
éventuellement une prise de parole on
n'en savait rien à ce moment-là de la
famille des motivations politiques et
cetera je trouve que ça ça me révolte
mais alors cyil tu peux pas
savoir ça je vais te dire ça on va
remettre la une ça prendre un truc sur
une intelligence artificielle on faire
la Une c'est vraiment euh libération
c'est c'est un c'est un et tout àilleur
manuel Vals parlait de cette de cette
grande difficulté dans laourd avec les
fake news il faut que tout le monde
intègre que des fausses nouvelles des
fausses vidéos ça sert aussi la guerre
de communication entre les deux camps et
malheureusement là c'est un naufrage oui
il nous était tombé dessus quand j'avais
dit j'avais dit que la France comptait
trois villes françaises parmi les plus
dangereuses et donc ils avent fait un
article en disant une fake news mais en
fait c'était pas au monde je crois que
c'était en Europe donc c'est encore une
fois le chameau qui se moque du bossus
c'est le rock fort qui dit au camber tu
pu voilà donc libération malheureusement
la naufrage d'un journal qui enc
libération je vous le demande voilà
personne on va pas se mentir s'ils en
vendent six par jour c'est le bout du
monde euh